Bet you didn't expect me coming from there.
Did ya?
Y'all think you know everything about me, don't you?
Ooh..
PoodiePie makes another one of these? Oh! He makes another one of these!
I've got plenty of tricks up my sleeves *shows sleeves*
But let's review what you guys did for last week, okay?
Okay, another week of disappointment?
PROBABLY
another week of...
"HE DOESNT MAKE ORIGINAL CONTENT"
Last week, I asked you to...
I don't remember...*alzheimer's*
I don't remember what I asked you to do last week
It's not like you're gonna accept the challenge anyway, but let's watch let's review them
For the yugioh fan.
The god of wamen.. Look at those nipples man.
Hell yeah! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
You see those nipples those nipples are perfect nipples.
Okay? A lot of guys. They have weird nipples. Let's just get that out of the way here
I think 9 out of 10 guys have weird nipples. My nipples are absolute pristine
Top quality nipples, and this is not some sort of meme around my nipples
I'm 100% serious.
If they were to make a sample out of my nipples
It would be the perfect sample because my nipples are 10 out of 10. Okay. Got a little off-topic there
Uhm..
It's a good card in Yu-gi-oh. He's doing it again.
*someone alert the WSJ*
I Can't control what my dog does it's different!
Didn't a youtuber go to jail for like teaching his dog how to do Nazi salutes?
That's horrible. That's horrific. How did I do?
(laughs)
Fake version of Pewdiepie
I like you have a black cat in there.
Yeah. Where's your beard, buddy? Huh? Where is this?
You can rip on me all you want, but there's no way you can get over this boy!
Uhh! It stings doesn't it?
to be a low level life tier of a wannabe
Where's your whiskey then huh you see the whiskey? What are you drinking? Huh?
I bet you're not even drinking. Bet you're too young. Why am I so mean? I'm in the defense mode. Okay?
That's why. I don't want to I don't want this relationship between us to be toxic.
Zen, Zero, Hen...
*Pewds is buffering*
Henro?
Her?.. HERO!
*Clap*
I thought it would be something bad, so it never even crossed my mind that it would be something nice.
*Laughs*
This is so obvious
We need to talk about "We need to talk".
We need to talk (Clickbait)
We need to talk important (Clickbait)
wE neEd tO TaLk
Listen,you make one video every single day. You're gonna bound it...
*laughs*
There is no excuse. I know it,ok.
I MAKE A VIDEO EVERYDAY!!!
*laughs*
That's the excuse!
Best boyfriend ever *mumbles* PewDiePie: lol gay
*giggles*
Drew this as a birthday gift. Hope you like it, sister fister. That's awesome
Thank you very much for making me look very manly and very sexy
Roast me #ChristianChannel
Oh my GAH!
That's awesome
Jesus himself came to my Christian Channel! Finally we're getting recognized!
Not that offensive Jesus the real Jesus. It's too bad. You're a week behind Jesus
Okay, that was last week roasting was last week's okay.
You can go back from where you came from.
Thank you.
As a father
It's my job to respect my son's opinion
Dad? (that sexy voice)
Yes, my dear son
pewdiepie makes original...* sniggering*  *shots fired*
I mean... I don't
Hey I
Clearly don't make any original content you laugh you lose
Is that not original content me reacting to other people's content is that not original content? Oh oh?( i dont know tell us my boi)
What's next you're gonna? Tell me me playing in a South Park. It's not original content. Oh, I'm sorry. Oh, I'm sorry well
How about me drinking whiskey then huh?
Felix Kjellberg?
Felix
iceberg
Carlsberg
No x (the amount of YLYL videos felix has made)
There's also Felix cat food yeah, I know cuz I love me some *don't say it*
*please no*
pusseh *goddamnit*
Photoshop my beard onto 2012 Markiplier.
me
I asked you to photoshop my beard. Can you do one thing I ask?
I'm in pewdiepie's video. This is mad. I'm freaking out wait so it's an actual YouTuber?
*I ain't subtitling that.*
That was a weird experience.
I'm not gonna lie.
I want to do more VR chat though. That was fun
That's cool, man. Great to meet you great to awkwardly hug with you in VR, which never made it
You know it's great that I can't leave my house without getting recognized now and escape from you guys, and now I can't even
*bangs desk*
*rare animal noises*
That's actually pretty cool. I like the little thing you gave me there very nice
You know I'll give it a very nice another very nice
Not very nice - a VAHRY nice
It's different. If you don't know the difference, you're a fake fan, ok, you're a fake fan.
Christian Channel
Thank You
Felix makes disgusting, disgustinger (Is that a word?).
of course you're gonna take anything
because I'm wearing the catnip ears of course you're gonna take anything personal that I
Shared about my past which is sensitive topic and use it against me. Thank you. I always appreciate sharing stuff about myself
It's very nice; not very nice.
I've seen this meme. This is a good meme obnoxious, but popular
youtubers starter pack
We got the hair. I'm glad my hair is not included. six- a lot of subscribers (laugh)
Yeah, they're also popular too. Starts every video with the loud greeting.
Well I didn't, can we run it back?
*We've broken time*
Bet you didn't expect me coming from there did ya?
Yep, that's right ok
I don't have those anymore,
cuz you know why they're so annoying to do you have to spray them on with spray glue
And it's literally impossible to take them off. It's not worth it the acoustics are fine alright
You need your only to bless your home thing. I'm pretending you're some sort of top level tier artist who's recording
I don't know who cares okay, who cares a very shocked face and emoji in the thumbnail well they work
Okay, if you have a problem with them stop clicking on THEMMMMMMMMM
video length 10:19 10:04 10 hey hey, hey, okay listen
huh 45
30 - okay, maybe that one, 40, all right so stop bitching
Try not to laugh challenge
528 excuse me try not to laugh challenge
Episode 1. Okay, sorry I made one episode and then
My chair is way better than that garbage come on this this thing is 10 out of 10
You wish you had this chair
You can make fun of the chair all you want
But you sit in this chair once and you're not gonna want to sit on anything else and even my yes
I'm talking about your mom's ass. Pewdiepie swestian kid that plays minecraft respect women
And he is an extreme alcoholic he had never died before
He had never died before that's right that is another it's another take of my catchy catchy catchphrase
Zero death, but I think I will change it to 'I had never died before'. when you're three minutes into your stream
And you haven't said the N word yet, it's funny
This is kind of mean people posted against me like oh look at this idiot, but it's funny
Don't be racist be like PewDiePie. He is from Sweden
speaks
English has a hot
Italian girlfriend and talks like a black dude top come and I was like how does he talk like a bla?
The new word. 'Swestian: a person who is Swedish by origin and also
Christian'. We added a new word to the vocabulary you're welcome, world. Swestian. Swestian channel,
Thank you! Ends every you laughs you lose video by saying:
Did you laugh or did you lose, but laugh equal lose and and lose also equals lose
Oh, wow took you long enough to realize did you laugh, or did you lose?
It's a paradox either way you lose, and I win. You wanted it - damn that looks good
It looks like a like a Dragon Ball character something very nice
When you see someone respecting women wait, what is happening? Oh?
It's this South Park is when you had to do the
Spinning thing god damn it you guys are perverted. Okay?
Best polish remover damn it listen listen I get so much shit for this outfit. Okay?
Everyone is all "OH he dressed up as a Nazi
How could he do that?" literally go to Amazon and search soldier costume? Hey? What is that? What is that? Huh?
What is that? It's a very nice costume.
'How could you dress up like a Nazi??'
yeah, no it's like no one has ever done that before isn't it happy birthday to you Swedish meatball
Oh, that's so sweet
That's such a nice fan art, but too bad It's a MICROAGGRESSION!
Just cuz I'm Swedish doesn't mean. I'm a meatball
DAHH! Throw it in the trash. I'm sorry. I tried. top ten Pewdiepie neanderthal depictions
The colors are great
That nose is amazing...
That nose is like
It's like a water slide you really h- thank you. This really helps my insecurities about how giant my nemesis
Thank you very much. We have good internet down here. Please. I will do anything
I'm not joking I'm on my fourth month now since I ordered the internet
They started digging yesterday
Outside my house, and they they broke the internet they didn't told me they were coming. I'm so done guys
Please. To make people think you're not out of ideas...
These are good, man. Literally the same - 'because you played Dark Souls'
I knew it! I knew it!
Okay, we're gonna end that episode there well done. That was really fun. You know what I'm gonna give you an A very nice.
A very nice. Since you guys make fun of me for not coming up with my own original ideas this week
I'm not even gonna bother doing that. I'm not even gonna bother
Challenge you guys. You can just post whatever you want because that's what you're doing anyway.
on the real, on the flip side
Can we horizontal flip this video one second so I can be real I appreciate you guys these are funny memes
And I'm glad I can just laugh at them and make content at the same time
And I hope that you guys as a community enjoy the same type of weird humor as well
Okay, flip me back you guys fucking suck
Thank you for leaving it like and remember to squad fam Jiu Jitsu as always
Very nice